The David Pakman Show subreddit is approaching
a huge milestone.
Twenty thousand subscribers.
You can find it at David Pakman dot com slash
rbd d-i t.
Couple interesting posts from this morning.
Lime guy asked how many of you are friends
with trombonists?
Do you think politics matters with friends?
This is something I've never come to a conclusion
on though.
I find people who believe really dumb crap
can be annoying to me like Trump apologists.
You know, for me, the conflicts with conservative
acquaintances and friends are are rarely about
politics themselves, but it's about something
indirectly related to their worldview.
So like we rarely argue about electoral politics
or abortion or stuff like that.
But what gets irritating and tends to cause
conflict is that their political views are
linked to a generally bizarre world view,
which might include, you know, aggressive
skepticism of science or conspiratorial thinking
about uncontroversial institutions or whatever
the case may be.
So in my experience, the difficulty with acquaintances,
colleagues, friends that whose politics are
different is not so much about the politics
of electoral decisions, so to speak, but more
just that, like their politics are just part
of a worldview.
That to me is difficult to be around, and
very often I end up sort of opting out.
I'm talking about pretty radical people here,
like some kind of moderate centrist where
we disagree on on fiscal policy.
It's not really a huge deal, but but that's
typically what happens.
The arguments aren't actually about Social
Security or abortion or gay marriage or whatever
the case may be.
I also posted by Reflex Point is a very interesting
section of Sam Harris interviewing Andrew
Yang on two issues.
Joe Biden's cognitive state, as well as Tara
Reid.
I encourage people to check this out.
I tend to have the same perspective as Andrew
Yang.
Here he explains when it comes to Joe Biden's
cognitive state that, listen, he's 78 and
thus he is a different person cognitively
to some degree, as he was when he debated
Paul Ryan eight almost nine years ago.
But that Andrew Yang has spent time with him
and Joe Biden is cognitively OK and that all
of the stuff that we're seeing is relatively
overblown.
That goes with what I'm seeing from the mental
health experts that I talked to and the neurologists
that I've spoken to.
I would not doubt for a second that Joe Biden
is not slowed down compared to who he was
nine, 12, 15, 20 years ago.
He's nearly 80 years old.
And this is something that happens.
But I concur with Andrew Yang on that.
Andrew Yang also says that he does not think
that the terror Reid story is going to explode
and be the prevailing narrative over the next
few months with Joe Biden.
And I also agree with that and I've explained
why earlier this week.
So check out that video if you haven't seen
it.
And then lastly.
Here is a question about the Imade arbitrary
case, a user named H0, H.H. 2:31 says, Is
it too soon to talk about how the father and
son who lynched the black jogger in Georgia
will likely be found innocent?
I don't know that I would even go into characterizing
it as a lynching or not and debating whether
the guy was jogging or not.
Everybody's disputing every one of these facts.
I hate to say it.
I really do.
But if you said, David, you've got a bet.
Do those guys end up being found guilty of
any felonies or not?
I say probably not.
That's probably the way that I would bet.
And we have to let the justice system run
its course.
Of course, the problem is when we don't trust
the justice system to properly adjudicate,
certain types of cases becomes more and more
difficult to do that.
But if you said, David, you've just you got
to bet you've got a bet on either they are
found not guilty or guilty of some minor misdemeanor
that they plead down to or these individuals
plead or are found guilty to felonies.
I bet that they're not found guilty of felonies.
OK.
Remember, you can join the discussion at David
Pakman dot com slash.
Read it.
It is free to subscribe.
And nearly 20000 of you have already done
that.